[Music]
what's my name
welcome to I know that we can have a
Friday as always I don't know what I
always do but that intro was made by an
a name here it was really awesome really
funny
Swedish dudes I guess first off everyone
is asking about the posters there's like
a last chance to get them if you want
one still and it's gonna look like this
the sizes are 50 x 60 this is the
weekend I can't really order them anyway
so I decided to keep it up for not
neither
over the weekend we can still order like
I said the instructions in the
description if you still want to get one
it's a sign PewDiePie posters in case
you have no idea what I'm talking about
or is it probably the case recently when
I read the comments basically more and
more occurring event is that hey guys
Jacob I know it's really good I don't
know I don't have any videos yet but
still ray I'm just not like that but I
know there's a lot of hard-working
youtubers out there that doesn't get the
attention that you deserve and I feel
you bro I remember I remember when I
used to have like 39 subs and I went
through 40 and I was like ah ye party
shows good so I know how it is I
remember I got four subs one day and I
was like oh boy sobs you friggin could
get out of here no this is so not enough
thought there are so many people out
there like I don't know I want to help
you bros out space simple as that so if
you you are you to run your outlet
videos and you run and get a chance
get more attention I will try and give
you a shout out in the next five SuperPi
if you want to enter this competition
alright let's try to make it more happy
Friday to appear to pie third
competition that just sounded really
stupid I'm sorry so basically you write
this text entry or something if you want
to want to enter this trinket in kruky
and basically I will have to set a
requirement that you have 100
subscribers to enter this simply because
of what I said before last time I did
this I there were so many people who
entered and it just it was too much I'm
sorry alright
as always as always I'm charging it you
know what that means get your brofist up
there and bros alright you ready you
ready for the brofist
you better be like brace yourself a
little bit there we go that's better
brace that way that just makes it look
silly
alright alright here we go
wanna why do I always do it at 4:00
today
[Music]